as a registered independent i've been a
voter republican i've owed a democrat
i'm a registered independent now for i
don't know 11 years or 12 years
something like that
and rogan you see he was a libertarian
he was voted he voted for joe jorgensen
which
i
i don't know if she'll ever come back i
i don't know if i don't know
i asked her back she was upset she
didn't want to come back on but
you put a fork in here but but the point
the point being is the following
he says with aaron rodgers he sits there
and he says well so what do we do and he
says vote republican aaron starts
laughing what did you think when rogan
is a guy that
you would have never thought rogan's
gonna say vote republican this guy
pushed to legalize marijuana this guy
pushed to
you know talking about certain things
that there's nothing about it would be
republican but a guy like kim is now
saying voting republican what was your
reaction when you saw that so when i saw
when i saw what rogan said i was it was
very similar to what i had when i saw
what zuckerberg did i was like good for
you joe like that's
like speak your heart if you're not if
you've got a voice you've got an awesome
voice man if you've got a voice speak
your heart if you're speaking to
anything else you're kind of wasting
your voice right joe spoke with his
voice zuck spoke with his voice i think
that's really good stuff it's important
to remember that human beings are not
left or right
human beings are all a mix of both
we just we want what we want that we we
are motivated by the things that are
important and motivate us
so you don't you're not all red you're
not all blue there's always a bell curve
so at the fat end of the bell curve
people are close to center people
believe in some things and believe in
other things but unfortunately media
doesn't give you a chance to be
supportive of both
media forces you to choose one or the
other and then they feed you lines from
one or the other and they move you
closer and closer to the outside of the
bell curve until you choose to just stop
reading the news or you choose to stop
watching tv or you choose to sit around
and drink beer and watch sports games
and [ __ ] about the news all day right
but media's in the business of forcing
you to one side the other human beings
are not like that right i believe a
woman should have the choice to take
care of her own body i do believe in the
sanctity of life but a woman should have
the choice to take care of her own body
but the government does not need to tax
me at 40
i can spend my money wisely on my own i
don't need them to police my money i
don't need them to police like what i'm
doing in my bedroom i don't need the
government to police how i raise my
children or whether they're homeschooled
or private school or whether i'm
dissatisfied with the public school
right we have we're all a mix
of of all sorts of different positions
and we are all getting frustrated by
being forced to pick one side or the
other should the government have access
to know if you have that word on your
butt that's the question
i think they're curious to know knowing
the way they are like if they maybe you
should stop mooning people so they want
to find out you know obviously that's an
analogy are there any news sources that
you they legitimately trust like you're
saying you know you don't trust the
media that was like your biggest
discrepancy with what today like what
outlets you say okay because pat said
that he
if when it comes to polls he said pew
and what was the other one rasmussen
gallop gallup he trusts that all right
they're not a hundred percent accurate
but with a level of certainty
probability like you terms of use
what what media outlets do you trust so
i don't i don't trust any of them fully
i trust at best i trust about 85
the way that i handle the news is i will
read competing news sources on the same
coverage on purpose and see where they
overlap right give us an example so the
wall street journal so the economist
okay the economist is a great example
we've got two minutes just so you know
absolutely sir the economy is a great
example cnn is a great example um fox
news is not such a great example yahoo
news is actually a decent usa today is
actually a decent example um al jazeera
is a decent example um bbc is a decent
example these are all places that i'm
like 80 85 percent even though they they
consistently what did you see about
something consistently lean one side i
don't look at msnbc cnn's on my list
only because they were very consistently
left
and when i started seeing them trash
talking biden about nine months ago i
was like there's a change in cnn right
they still go with popular opinion
they're still just trying to sell ad
space right but when it comes to who's
who's going to get my time i'll look at
them i'll cross-reference them i'll see
what's the same i'll see what's
different i'll believe what's the same
and i'll challenge what's different so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]